bitcoin ethereum doscoin
ripples xrp whatever your favorite
cryptocurrency is
wouldn't it be great if you could use an
accurate machine learning model that
could tell you exactly
when to buy or to sell keep watching and
we'll discuss
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
so a while ago i did a video on whether
or not data science could be an
effective tool for predicting the stock
market
and the conclusion i came to was while
it's definitely better than random
guessing
you're just not going to be able to do
it perfectly
and i broke down three reasons for that
the first was the efficient market
hypothesis
and this is basically the idea that all
of the currently known information
about the market is already baked into
the price
so it's kind of difficult for data
science or artificial intelligence to
really add much to that
the second is that it's really hard to
predict future shocks
i mean think about it this way if you
knew that the pandemic was going to
happen in 2020
you would have gone out and bought tons
and tons of zoom and tesla stock
but you didn't did you but the third
reason is that there's a bit of a
conflict of interest concerned
as far as creating something accurate
that predicts the market really well
and then sharing it because let's think
about it if everybody knew
exactly what the market was going to do
well it's a little difficult to
outperform that now isn't it
now bitcoin and the cryptocurrency
market in general
are much newer than stocks but they
operate under very similar principles
for one thing people are buying based on
institutional adoption and it's
very difficult to tell when if ever
these large institutions are going to
sell
it's hard to predict when if ever the
united states government or some other
government dropped some big bundle of
regulations on it
and the same idea of a conflict of
interest certainly applies here as well
now it's common to do either what's
called fundamental analysis or technical
analysis
in the cryptocurrency space as well as
in the stock market space
the idea with these is either to try to
estimate the intrinsic value of the coin
or to estimate where it's going in the
future based on trends and formations
that have happened in the past
that's its own thing and i'm not going
to get into all of that here
instead i'm going to strictly talk in
terms of things that my audience
understands
or at least may understand in the future
as they go through their data science
journey
which is machine learning and ai methods
with a healthy dose of course
of data science principles that are
general for all types of problems
before i do that though just some usual
asks number one smash the like button
for the youtube algorithm
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell
that way whenever i upload a video
youtube will notify you
and lastly i'll have a link in the
description of this video to my patreon
account
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over that way it would be
enormously appreciated
so usually when people talk about
predicting bitcoin price
they're talking about predicting it in
short-term windows so that they can make
trades they're not necessarily talking
about long-term prediction
there's not a lot out there on
predicting where the price is going to
be in a month or over a general
longer term horizon and when it has been
done
it's not exactly something that inspires
the most confidence
this is an analysis done by a data
scientist named marco santos
and his code is available on github with
an article posted on towards data
science in the fall of 2019
all about this exercise so he used a
seasonal
auto regressive integrated moving
average that is
a cerima model to predict the bitcoin
price
and as you can see when the prediction
was made the price was around 8
000 but the range one month out for this
prediction
was about five thousand dollars to
thirteen thousand dollars
now i'm not trying to pick on this guy
at all because on one hand he did a
great job
illustrating exactly what the
limitations of the time series model
are and he also did a really solid write
up of it that i highly recommend you
read
and it's not just him either facebook
can't get it more precise either
so here they did a similar prediction
over the next month
where they agree that the price is
moving in an upward trajectory
but their interval of uncertainty one
month out
is from 10 000 to 14 000.
in my book that difference matters these
are just a couple examples but i think
the takeaway is pretty clear
predicting anything one month out
especially bitcoin
is pretty hard that brings us to what i
think most people are interested in
which is day trading
and if you just do a google search for
data science and bitcoin
there's one particular term that seems
to come up over and over again
and that's long short-term memory or as
it's commonly abbreviated
lstm for those of you who are unfamiliar
the lstm is a deep learning method
and it's a type of recurrent neural
network that takes into account both
long-term dependencies as well as
short-term trends
and if you look at some of the output
from it it looks like a miracle
in fact in a couple different
applications of the lstm
after hyper parameter selection and all
that jazz
the unseen test data and the predicted
values
match one another astonishingly closely
now if all that sounds a bit too good to
be true well that's because it is
much credit to the author rafael schultz
craft aka
neocortex for putting together a great
blog
over at hacker noon which explains why
exactly this is so deceptive
here they zoom in on a one month horizon
and you can sort of get the idea that
the predicted values
just look shifted from the actual values
because as it turns out
what it's sort of doing is it's mostly
using the value from the previous day
but as you can see there's a point
towards the beginning where the actual
price shoots up but the prediction at
the same time goes down
meanwhile towards the end on the day
where the actual price
takes a big dip the prediction ticks up
slightly
now they were so kind here as to show
what happens when you take the same
graph and
shift the predictions back by one day
and it turns out then it's virtually
identical to the previous day's actual
data you don't need to be a professional
crypto trader to realize that
yes while this looks beautiful and
everything this is not exactly going to
be very useful from a practical
standpoint
but i don't want to be a total debbie
downer either you'll notice
in the examples that i've shown you so
far these things have
largely been based algorithmically on
the previous
price points over various points in time
sure there have been things taken into
account like daily trading volume
for example but for the most part these
things have relied on
pattern recognition using time series
data
an entirely different type of analysis
to throw into this whole discussion
is what's known as sentiment analysis
for those of you who don't know what
that is
it's the use of keywords and natural
language processing
to identify subjective opinions usually
by using freely available text data
and then to transform that into some
kind of structured and useful data
this is all another fairly modern branch
of ai
but you couple that with the fact that
it's pretty easy to extract text data
from places like reddit and twitter
you've got yourself a pretty solid
wealth of available data
as well as an enormous body of research
that's being done on this topic
plus anybody who's been following
cryptocurrency for a while
intuitively understands that elon musk
can tweet things
and the markets are going to respond in
a relatively pronounced fashion
but we should have the same natural
questions about this approach as we do
about any other
which is okay that's cool and everything
but does it do any good
well actually sentiment analysis is the
driver behind a fairly commonly used
tool both in crypto
and in the stock market which is the
fear and greed index
sentiment from different sources is
broadly characterized as greedy or
fearful
and then a score is provided the idea is
that if there's extreme fear it's a
buying opportunity
while if investors are too greedy though
then that means the market is due for a
correction
and this is a pretty common tool that
traders use to guide their decisions in
the crypto industry
and hey this isn't financial advice or
anything but as warren buffett once
famously said
maybe you should be fearful when other
people are greedy and you should be
greedy when other people are fearful
then that brings us to what's called the
bull and bear index
so this was developed by the service
augmento
which was acquired by german
professional advisory firm postera
capital
and you'll see they put a dashboard
together which tracks the sentiment
through a variety of sources including
twitter
reddit and bitcointalk in fact you can
hover over a particular part of the
graph
and see what keywords are trending
obviously correction and
dip are pretty negative these things are
classified in positive or negative ways
and it comes out to a final indexed
score again these are tools which get
used by traders all the
time and there are people out there who
swear by them
but nobody has a crystal ball however i
must say
i think there's tremendous promise with
sentiment analysis
and in this field of ai in general i
can't wait to see
what the future holds as we develop
better apis
people are able to extract better and
higher quality data
and then more research is done in this
field my overall
thoughts are very similar to what i said
in my stock market video
that is as data practitioners we need to
have a sense of humility
and realize we are never going to be
able to create or
find some perfect tool that's going to
be able to game the market
or for that matter any type of problem
and even if by some miracle
such a tool could be created the
developer of that tool would have
zero incentive to share that kind of
thing with the public
i think to the extent data science and
ai are going to help us with these
market problems
it's going to be a little bit more
subtle than that it's probably going to
look closer to these indices that i've
showed you here
and we're going to have to evaluate the
results across a probabilistic spectrum
that is when people make decisions based
on one tool
maybe they're right 75 percent of the
time as opposed to some other tool where
they're only right 65 percent of the
time
so we'll have to wait and see as these
tools mature people learn of new ways to
use them
and we come up with some solid and
robust ways of measuring performance
in the meantime i think this is a
wonderful case study in some
fairly general principles of data
science for just about everybody
number one nothing you create is ever
going to be perfect
and number two at the end of the day it
all comes down to understanding what
your use case is
and your data quality so thanks for
watching this video
if you enjoyed it tap the like button
consider
sharing it and also leave me a comment
down below
if you're involved in the crypto trading
sphere let me know what types of tools
you use
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data